I wanted to begin by talking a little bit about what,
what is the question or what is the problem to which this immense book,
uh,
of which you're only reading a,
I dunno,
a couple of hundred pages maximum.
What is the problem with which this huge book is concerned?
It's always an important question to ask when you begin a new book.
What question is the author trying to ask?
Or what problem is he trying to deal with?
Let me try to set up Tocqueville's problem,
uh,
in,
in the following way.
Uh,
in the 17th and 18th centuries,
the ideas of freedom and equality seemed to walk confidently hand in hand.
Uh,
Hobbs Loche who,
so who he's been reading all believed that in the state of nature,
remember we were all born free and equal as long as the enemy appeared to be the
entrenched hierarchies of power and privilege of the old regime,
of the old monarchical societies.
Freedom.
Inequality were taken to be mutually reinforcing aspects,
uh,
of the emerging,
democratic,
uh,
order
and it,
but it was not until the beginning of the 19th century with the emergence of the
democracies or Prodo democracies,
a of Europe and the new world,
uh,
that political philosophers,
political thinkers,
began to wonder where their freedom and equality did not in fact,
pull in different directions.
Tocqueville in particular,
although you could add the names like Benjamin Constante or,
or,
or John Stuart Mill,
but Tocqueville in particular saw the new democratic societies,
is creating new forms of social power,
new types of rule that represented in some ways organized threats to human
liberty.
What were these new forms of social power?
These were for Tocqueville,
the new middle class,
or what we might call bourgeois democracy is the new middleclass democracies
emerging in countries like France,
England,
and of course,
the United States.
And the problem for Tocqueville,
or his question as it was for Locke and others before him,
was how to mitigate the effects of political power.
How does one,
uh,
control or mitigate,
for political power?
Yes.
Right.
You can see that,
uh,
lacks answer you recall to this problem was to divide and separate the separated
powers.
A theme clearly taken up and endorsed by the American constitutional framers,
but Tocqueville was less certain that this kind of institutional device,
so to speak,
of checks and balances are separated powers could be ineffective or truly
effective check,
uh,
in a democratic age where you might say the people as a whole had become king.
He was less certain that institutional remedies alone could work.
Was 75 years before talk though,
right?
Wrote democracy in America,
Russo had taken up the doctrine of popular sovereignty to be an ideal to be
worked for taking men as they are and laws as they might be.
He looked to the doctrine of popular sovereignty is something that could be,
but Tocqueville again,
writing seven approximately 75 years after Rousseau saw this doctrine,
this doctrine of popular sovereignty that far mid 18th of mid 18th century
Frenchmen had looked like a far flung utopian ideal for Tocqueville.
This ideal had become an altogether a political reality that had taken shape in
the backwoods of Jacksonian America considered just the following passage from
the democracy in the United States.
Tocqueville writes,
the Democ,
the dogma,
he says,
he calls it the dogma of the sovereignty of the people is not an isolated
doctrine that is joined neither to habits,
nor to the sum of dominant ideas.
On the contrary,
he says,
one can view it as the last link in a chain of opinions that envelops the Anglo
American world as a whole.
And he goes on to say that extended to the entirety of the nation,
it becomes it.
That is,
this opinion becomes the dogma of the sovereignty of the people.
So here you have Tocqueville's view that,
uh,
this roo in concept of popular sovereignty has become,
an existence reality.
And for Tocqueville,
there was no reason to believe that the new democratic states,
uh,
emerging again in America and in Europe.
These new democratic states ruled by the people.
There was no reason to believe that they will be more just or less arbitrary
than any other previous kind of regime.
For Tocqueville,
no one,
no person or body of persons can be safely and trusted with political power.
And the United Power of the people do.
United sovereignty of the people is no more for him.
A reliable guarantor of freedom than any other kind of regime.
So the problem of politics you might say in,
in age of democracy is the problem of how to control the sovereignty of the
people.
For Roussel,
you remember that was never really seriously a problem.
The general will,
he says,
cannot err.
Uh,
the people,
uh,
when they are ruling in their collective capacities cannot be wrong.
Uh,
but Tocqueville was less certain about this,
whether or not the people,
uh,
in their collective capacity as sovereign,
are,
uh,
an infallible guide.
The question is what can be done about that?
Uh,
in an aristocratic ages,
you might say the answer was simple.
Tocqueville believed that in aristocratic times there were always countervailing
centers of power,
a king's no matter how powerful,
always had to contend with,
uh,
a fractious and warlike a nobilities.
But again,
who or what can exercise that countervailing power in a world where the people
in their collective capacity have to repeat,
become the king,
uh,
who or what has the power to check the popular will or the general will.
This is the problem.
How to check democratic power.
This is the problem that Tocqueville's new political science.
What he boasts in the introduction to the book is a new political science for a
world itself.
Quite new.
Uh,
this is the problem that he sets out to answer.
And to this extent,
I would also say we are all Tocqueville's children.
We are all disciples of Tocqueville.
In so far as we all are,
political science continues to deal with the problem of the guidance and control
of democratic government.
How to,
you might say,
combine popular government with political wisdom,
how to do that remains a problem.
You might say,
akin to squaring the circle,
but it remains the fundamental problem for democracies.
How to combine popular rule with political wisdom.
That was really what Tocqueville was concerned about.
Okay.
But before going on.
But before going on,
let me
ask,
who was,
who was Alexi de Tocqueville?
Let's say?
Let me tell you something about him.
Yeah.
Tocqueville was born in 1805 into a Norman family from the north of France,
from Normandy with an ancient lineage.
The Tocqueville is state,
still stands today and his own still in the hands of members of the Tocqueville
family.
I know because I visited it a couple of summers ago and met and met his heirs,
although they are not actually the heirs of his,
of him directly.
Uh,
Tocqueville and his wife had no children.
They belong to one of the brother's side of the family,
but absolutely charming people.
Exactly what you think French aristocrats would be like.
Our charm and grace.
Okay,
wonderful hosts.
And Tocqueville was deeply attached to his ancestral home.
Uh,
in a letter from 1828,
one of my favorite Tocqueville letters he wrote to a friend.
Here I am after returning from a trip abroad trip away,
here I am finally at Tocqueville,
referring to the home simply by the family name.
I am finally at Tocqueville.
And my family's old broken down,
ruined it'll leagues distance.
I can see the harbor where William the conqueror sets sail for England.
I am surrounded by Norman Norman's,
whose names figure among the conquerors.
All of this I have to confess,
tickles my heart.
So he,
he comes from a line of people who trace their ancestry back to the Norman
conquest and have been in that part of France for centuries,
for centuries.
In fact,
the Tocqueville home,
it's a short drive away from the Normandy beach where the big d day invasion
took place.
You know,
during World War Two,
it's a miracle that the home still survives.
Tocqueville's parents had been arrested during the French revolution and were
held in prison for almost a year and only the fall,
uh,
of Robespierre and 1794 saved them from execution.
Uh,
the young Tocqueville was born,
uh,
under the Napoleonic dynasty and spent his formative years is,
is adolescence in his school years under the most conservative,
uh,
if not to say reactionary circles of post revolutionary France.
Tocqueville,
studied law in Paris,
and during this time he made the acquaintance and friendship of another young
Aristocrat by the name of Gustaf to Beaumont and an 1830 for reasons that are
not altogether clear when he was,
when he was 25 or so.
In 1830,
the two men received a commission from the new government of Louis,
Felipe King,
Louie Felipe to go to the United States to study the prison system there.
The trip to the u s was occasioned by a of grant,
you might say,
a fellowship to study the American prison system.
Uh,
talk thoughts journey to America,
which has been extensively documented.
Lasted for just under a year from May,
1831 to February,
1832 and during that time he traveled as far north as New England south to New
Orleans.
Yes,
he was in New Orleans and went to the outer banks of Lake Michigan.
Uh,
the result of this visit was of course the two large volumes that he called
democracy in America,
democracy on a Merrick.
Uh,
the first volume appeared five years,
four years or so after his trip in 1835,
uh,
when it's Arthur was only 30 years old.
The second volume appeared five years later in 1840.
And both of those volumes are contained within the single volume that you have.
Uh,
Tocqueville's trip has been much studied and much admired.
Even just,
uh,
in,
in recent,
very recent times,
uh,
a French philosopher by the name of Bernard Henri Levy came over,
didn't exactly follow Tocqueville's journey,
but traveled throughout America,
uh,
kind of,
Frenchmans Guide,
a sort of barrettes America or most going to lots of vague going to Las Vegas
and evangelical churches and all this stuff,
and wrote a very interesting book called American Vertigo.
Uh,
the most charitable thing I can remark is that he was no Tocqueville,
but leaving that aside,
it was a,
an admirable effort,
uh,
democracy in America to put it simply is the most important work about democracy
that you will ever read.
Uh,
to compound the irony,
uh,
the most famous book on American democracy was written by a French aristocrat
who might've been deeply foreign,
if not hostile to the manners customs habits of a democratic society.
And from the time of its first publication in 1835,
the book was hailed as a masterpiece.
John Stuart mill called the book a masterpiece that has,
once he says,
taken it to rank among the most remarkable productions of our time.
Tocqueville has to take his side,
his place alongside of Washington,
Jefferson and Madison,
almost as if he were an honorary American.
And as if this were not enough.
A recent translation of the book,
uh,
was recently inducted into the prestigious library of America series a,
which seems to put the stamp of naturalization,
uh,
and a book written in French for Frenchmen.
And yet yet it,
it is part of the prestigious library of America,
uh,
is Tocqueville might've said,
you know,
go figure,
uh,
I don't want to say that in French actually,
but,
um,
but there is a textbook image of Tocqueville according to which he came to
America is a kind of blank slate.
And the experience of American democracy had a profoundly transformative
influence over the young aristocrat.
But nothing I would suggest to you could be further from the truth.
In a letter to his best friend,
a man named Louis decare Galle,
who's home,
who's a state is actually directly next door to the Tocqueville estate.
Uh,
in a letter to Tocqueville written just before the publication of the first
volume of the democracy in 1835,
Tocqueville describes his purpose in writing his book in these terms.
Let me read from his letter.
Tocqueville writes,
it is not without having carefully reflected that.
I decided to write the book.
I am just now publishing.
I do not hide from myself what is annoying in my position,
it is bound to attract active sympathy from no one.
Some will find that at bottom.
I do not like democracy and them severe toward it,
but others will think I favor.
It's develop development in moderately.
It would be most fortunate for me if the book were not red.
And that is a piece of good fortune that may perhaps soon come to pass.
I know all that,
but here is my response.
Nearly 10 years ago,
I was already thinking about part of the things that,
how you've just now set forth.
I was in America only to become clear on this point.
The penitentiary system was a pretext.
So two points I think bear comment about this remarkable statement of his
purpose to his friend [inaudible].
First is the Tocqueville indicates that his idea for the book,
uh,
had already as he says,
Co begun to germinate five years before his trip to America.
He says the penitentiary system,
that penitentiary project for which he was sent over was only a pretext.
He said he already had begun to speculate on these themes.
He says 10 years before his trip,
uh,
now if you do the math,
when you consider that he was 30 years old in 1835 when the book was pub first,
first volume was published and he said he was speculating on these themes
already 10 years before.
It would seem that the germ of the idea for the book,
the germ idea,
that germ cell for the book had occurred to Tocqueville when he was only 20
years old.
That is to say about the age that most of you are here and he went to America
only to confirm what he had begun to suspect when he was at the age of
contemporary undergraduate.
Uh,
think of that.
get your idea now.
Get it quickly.
Then maybe you can write a famous book by the time you are 30.
Uh,
I have to tell you it is way,
way beyond that stage for me.
Okay.
Hobbes,
however,
did not write his masterpiece,
uh,
until he was 63.
So there's still hope for some of us.
Nevertheless,
the second point I would make about that letter is that it is also clear that
Tocqueville was writing his book,
not for the benefit of Americans who you will discover he thought had little
taste for philosophy.
But for freshmen in particular,
he was hoping to persuade his fellow countrymen who was still devoted to the
restoration of the monarchy,
that the democratic social revolution that he had witnessed in America
represented also the future of France.
If John Locke had said in his second treatise when lock had said in the
beginning,
all the world was America,
Tocqueville's point appears to be in the future.
All of the world will be,
uh,
America is attitude towards what he saw,
what we would perhaps call today,
Americanization democratization.
We,
his attitude towards this was one of skepticism mixed with fear.
I confess,
he writes it in America.
I saw more than America.
I sought their in image of democracy itself.
Or it's pensions,
it's characters.
It's prejudice is its passions.
I wanted to become acquainted with it,
if only to know at least what we ought to hope or fear from it.
That sentence is so typical of Tocqueville.
The way he,
he piles on the,
you know,
the quality,
the quality that the descriptive labels,
it's pensions,
it's character,
its prejudices,
it's passions.
So there are embedded in that two questions too.
You might say subordinate clauses are two sub questions that Tocqueville set out
to answer the first concerns,
the gradual replacement of the onsie on regime.
That is to say the French term for the old aristocratic order based on
privileges,
hierarchy,
deference,
and inequality with a new democratic society based on equality.
How did this happen?
And what brought it about this immense transform social and political
transformation from the old regime,
from an age of inequality to an increasing age of equality.
A huge example of what we might call today,
regime change or regime transformation,
and the second not expire.
How did that happen?
And the second,
not perhaps explicitly ask question,
but nevertheless a question on virtually every page of Tocqueville's book
concerns the difference between the form democracy has taken in America and the
form it took in France during their revolutionary period.
Why Tocqueville asks,
has American democracy been relatively gentle or mild?
Those are two characteristic Tocqueville,
union terms.
Why has American democracy been,
what we might call today a liberal democracy?
And why did democracy in France veer dangerously close towards terror and
despotism during its revolution?
Uh,
that was the second question.
Tocqueville set out to answer.
Tocqueville believed it to be virtually a providential fact of history that
societies were becoming increasingly democratic,
increasingly egalitarian.
We might say,
what is not certain you could say is what form democracy will take,
whether democracy will be compatible with liberty or whether it will issue into
a new kind of despotism remains a question that this,
that only the Statesman of the future we'll be able to answer.
And from these two questions,
how did this transformation occur and what form will democracy take in the
future?
From these two questions,
we can see that Tocqueville wrote,
his book is a political educator,
that Tocqueville takes his place along with people like Plato,
Aristotle,
Machiavelli,
and the others is a great political educator.
He was more than a mere chronicler of American manners and customs,
but rather it was an educator of future European statesmen hoping to steer their
countries between the shoals of revolution and reaction.
How did Tocqueville a attempt to accomplish this?
Let me try to talk for a moment about what he hoped to teach
because you have to admire the book.
And have to understand it,
uh,
as an immense handbook almost as it were,
of the education of a democratic statesmen.
Slightly larger than Machiavelli's prince perhaps,
but nevertheless a handbook for states craft statecraft.
Nonetheless,
what did he hope to teach
near near the end of the introduction and I pay a special attention to that,
that fascinating introduction to the book.
I don't,
I don't mean the translator's introduction.
I mean Tocqueville zone introduction.
Near the end of the introduction,
he writes the following sentence.
I think those who want to regard it,
namely his bark who wants to regarded closely,
we'll find in the entire work a mother thought that so,
so to speak,
links all the parts a mother thought his word sharing is an e De Mer,
a mother idea.
What is this mother idea or mother thought to which he refers there and the most
likely candidate for it.
Central idea is the idea of equality.
The opening sentence of the book reads among the new objects that attracted my
attention during my stay in the United States.
None struck my eye more vividly than the equality of conditions.
The equality of conditions.
What does he mean by that phrase?
What does it mean by a quality here?
Note in the first incidence that Tocqueville riff speaks of equality as a social
condition.
Uh,
an equality of conditions,
not a form of government per se.
Uh,
this is in part an expression of what you might think of is Tocqueville,
sociological imagination,
equality of conditions precedes democratic government.
Uh,
equality of conditions you might say is the cause from which democratic
governments arise.
Equality of conditions were planted both in Europe and in America long before
Democratic governments arose in either place.
Democratic governments are only is old.
It,
at least in France and America,
democratic governments are only as old as the American or French revolutions.
But equality of conditions had been prepared by deep rooted historical processes
that began long before the dawn of the modern age.
So a quality of conditions refers to a social fact,
not a form of government in,
in that intro,
which had in which precede democratic government,
uh,
by long periods of time.
And in the introduction to his book,
again,
Tocqueville gives a brief,
I would say very brief history of equality,
taking it as far back,
uh,
to the heart of the Medieval world.
Uh,
some 700 years.
He says,
unlike Hobbs or Russo,
he does not invoke a state of nature as a way of grounding equality.
In fact,
for Tocqueville,
what Hobbes and Rousseau believed that we are by nature,
free and equal in only over time,
they believe we're social hierarchies and inequalities introduced.
Tocqueville argues exactly the opposite point of view.
The historical process,
so to speak,
has been moving away from inequality and towards greater and greater equality of
social conditions.
The historical process,
at least as Tocqueville traces it out here,
has been a process of gradual,
uh,
it equalization of social conditions.
His equality is something like an historical force,
something that has been working itself out in history over a vast stretch of
time.
And he often writes as if equality is not just one fact among others,
but his,
what he calls a generative fact from which everything else derives.
As I studied America more and more,
he writes,
I saw an a quality of conditions I saw in the equality of conditions,
the generative fact from which each particular fact seems to issue.
He says in the second paragraph of his introduction,
the generative fact from which each particular fact seemed to issue.
Tocqueville writes here about equality,
uh,
as an historical fact that has come to acquire an almost providential force,
over time.
And he uses this term providence here several times throughout the introduction.
He uses that term not so much to describe God as one might think,
ah,
but rather to describe a sort of universal historical process that is working
itself out,
so to speak,
even against the intentions of individual social and political actors.
The gradual spread of the conditions of equality he believes has two characters,
uh,
or two characteristics of Providence.
It is universal,
he says,
and it always escapes the power of the individual to control.
If Machiavelli believed we can control for tuna,
we can control providence or chance.
Half the time.
Russ Tocqueville seems to believe that the process of equality,
uh,
always escapes the powers,
of human control.
It is the very power of equality that makes it seem to be an irresistible force,
uh,
rather than the product of the modern age alone.
Again,
Tocqueville shows have the steady emergence of equality of conditions has been
the central dynamic of European history over several hundreds of years.
So this,
he frames the book within a,
you might say a very large scale sort of philosophy of history in which
democracy equality and the gradual equalization of social conditions are the
sort of central motifs.
Okay.
So it is in order to understand that process that Tocqueville turns to America
of the 1830s,
there was only one country in the world.
He says where the great social revolution I am speaking of seems nearly to have
attained its natural limits.
One Country where the social revolution,
the democratic transformations from the old
aristocratic order to the new democratic age seems to have reached its natural
limits.
And that country is of course the United States.
Yeah.
In this context,
I think it is very revealing that he chose to call his book democracy in America
and not simply American democracy.
Think about that choice of title for a moment.
His point I take it is that is not that democracy is a peculiarly American
phenomenon,
far from it.
His point is when he's describing democracy in America,
here is the form that the democratic revolution has taken in America.
Uh,
what form it will take elsewhere or it may take elsewhere,
is by no means predetermined.
Democracy is not a settled or fixed condition.
It is something more like a process.
And when we think of the way we speak today,
when we talk about democratization,
the process of democratization,
you can see that democracy seems to be less a settled or fixed or determine it
kind of regime than a kind of process.
It has the quality that Rousseau referred to in the second discourse as
perfectability tape perfectability.
That is to say an almost infinite elasticity and openness to change.
Uh,
again,
it is less a determinant,
political or social order than a continual work in pro in progress.
And that is the way Tocqueville looks at,
uh,
America in some ways.
There looks at the future of democracy when he says,
I look at the place where it seems to have attained it's natural limit,
but what form it may take elsewhere is by no,
that is by no means to say that the form it takes in America is the form it will
take anywhere,
anywhere else.
Democracy is the regime that seems to be almost infinitely elastic in terms of
its possibilities.
And this I think is a profound and astute observation about the nature of
democratic government.
We do not know,
uh,
where the process of democratization will end any more today than we did in
Tocqueville's time or that Tokyo new.
It is a matter for statecraft and leadership and political thought.
Again,
we'll future democracies be liberal and freedom loving or will they be harsh and
rhubarb native.
That is a question that we are now seeing very upfront and close in various
parts of the world today that are undergoing their own very tempestuous
transitions to democracy as we was,
we'll say.
And it remains very much an open question.
What form those democracies will take.
Uh,
that question is at least as important for us,
uh,
if not more so than it was for Tocqueville.
What Tocqueville is sure about,
however,
is that the fate of America is in some way the fate of Europe.
And maybe for that matter,
the fate of the rest of the world.
It appears to me,
he says beyond doubt that sooner or later we shall arrive,
likely Americans at an almost complete equality of conditions.
He says in the introduction that we shall arrive speaking to his French
audience,
a shocking statement again,
two members of his class and of,
of,
of his family background that sooner or later we too will arrive at this
complete equality is,
seems to ask the reader,
do you like what you see?
Uh,
what I describe what form democracy will take elsewhere will be very much
dependent upon circumstance and statesmanship.
Again,
his is an attempt to educate a statesman for the future.
Let me say a few words.
Uh,
and I will
not finish this today,
but we'll,
we'll take it up to continue this a bit on Wednesday.
Yeah.
About what,
what were the characteristics of American democracy demark?
What constitutes,
as it were,
democracy,
American style as,
as Tocqueville?
Uh,
understood.
Given that again,
democracy has no single determinant farm but is characterized by a,
by a considerable degree of elasticity and openness.
What are the features that cons that are constitutive of American democracy?
Condensing a vast amount of material from especially from value one of
democracy.
There are three features that I want to,
uh,
emphasize,
about the characteristic,
the unique characteristics of American democracy that lead to,
again,
making it mild,
gentle,
or what we might call a liberal democracy.
These are local government civil associations and what Tocqueville calls the
spirit of religion.
Yeah.
And I want to talk about each of these three in turn out.
I'll only probably talk about the first one here.
Local,
local government,
one of the parts of Tocqueville spoke for which he is most famous.
The first and in many respects,
most fundamental feature of American democracy is the importance that
Tocqueville attributes to local government and local institutions.
The importance of localism,
local democracies and this,
and you might say the spirit that emanates from it is the spirit,
is the key to the whole,
uh,
the cradle of democracy is to be found in what Tocqueville calls the commune or
what in our translation is called the township,
the township democracy.
It is nonetheless in the township.
He writes that the force of free peoples resides.
The institutions of a township are to freedom what primary schools are to
science.
They put it within the reach of the people.
Does that sound at all familiar?
I mean,
I think it should,
uh,
in some respect,
Tocqueville's description of the New England township,
uh,
put within the reach of all the people clearly demonstrates the influence on
Tocqueville Russo's account of the general will and his social contract,
right.
It is the people organizing,
legislating and deliberating over their common interests.
That is the core of liberty.
Uh,
Tocqueville very much views the American experience of local democracy through
the lenses.
A shaped are crafted by Rousseau and this is hardly fortuitous.
In a famous letter again to his friend Care Galle.
Tocqueville admits that Rousseau was one of three writers with whom he spent
some time every day,
every day.
You read Rousseau every day,
the other two Monto,
skier and Pascal,
but it was Russo more than any other figure who again helped him understand the
democratic,
uh,
experience and particularly this experience of the township.
Yet in some ways,
Russo,
Tocqueville combines Roussel,
his reading of the township has Rusello and reading of the township with a kind
of Aristotelian twist.
The township,
he writes,
he continues in that same passage is the sole association that is so much in
nature.
He says that everywhere men,
our guard,
we're everywhere.
Men are gathered at township forms of itself.
That term in nature,
it is the sole association.
So much in nature should alert you to a kind of [inaudible] in what Rousseau?
Uh,
in what Tocqueville is saying.
The township is here said to be a product of nature.
It eludes,
he writes the effort of man.
The township exists by nature,
but it's cause existence is far from being guaranteed.
It is fragile and it is uncertain.
It is continually threatened by invasions,
not necessarily by foreign powers,
but from larger forms of government,
state and federal government.
The township is concern,
continually threatened by federal and National Authority and Tocqueville ads
with a definite hand of Rousseau that the more enlightened,
uh,
people are,
the more enlightened they are,
the more difficult it is for them to retain the spirit of the township.
Think of that.
The more enlightened they are,
the township relies on a certain kind of spirit of,
of local,
uh,
sturdy and steady habits,
not necessarily enlightened opinion.
Uh,
that spirit of local freedom,
again,
it goes hand in hand with,
with a kind of Rustic,
even primitive,
uh,
manners and customs that clearly Russo would have admired.
And for this reason,
he laments that the spirit of the township no longer exists in Europe,
uh,
where the process of political centralization and the progress of enlightenment
have virtually destroyed the conditions for local self government.
Uh,
I'm going to end on that note and,
and Wednesday we're going to show a little movie again,
a little piece from a movie about just a very,
very short clip,
which will illustrate the theme of Civil Associations and democracy.
And we'll go on to talk about religion and then some other parts of himself.
Well,
welcome back.
It's nice to see you all here.